SUNDAY>> Bret: JOHN, THANKS.
THE FORMER NUMBER 2 OF THE FBI
WHO WAS TERMINATED HOURS BEFORE
RETIREMENT IS FACING SERIOUS
LEGAL TROUBLE.
CATHERINE HAS THE LATEST ON
THAT.
>> A SOURCE CONFIRMS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WATCH DOG
MADE A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO THE
U.S. ATTORNEY HERE.
THEY SAID McCABE LIED 3 TIMES
UNDER OATH ABOUT HIS ROLE IN THE
FBI'S INVESTIGATION OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON FOUNDATION.
IT MIRRORS THE LANGUAGE
CONTAINED IN A FEDERAL STATUTE
THAT COVERS LYING TO FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS AND READS IN PART:
IN OUR VIEW THE EVIDENCE IS
SUBSTANTIAL.
DIRECT COMEY SAID HE HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE REFERRAL.
>> GIVEN THAT THE IG'S REPORT
REFLECTS INTERACTIONS THAT
ANDREW McCABE HAD WITH ME, I
COULD NOT BE A WITNESS.
>> CRIMINAL REFERRALS ARE
USUALLY SECRET.
McCABE'S LAWYER TOLD FOX NEWS WE
ARE CONFIDENT UNLESS THERE IS
INAPPROPRIATE PRESSURE FROM HIGH
LEVELS OF THE ADMINISTRATION THE
U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WILL
DECLINE TO PROSECUTE.
TWO SOURCES TOLD FOX NEWS THE
SEVEN COMEY MEMOS COULD BE
DELIVERED TO CAPITOL HILL BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AS SOON AS
TONIGHT AFTER FOX NEWS CONFIRMED